I would say when the beastie boys pulled
off the first Tibetan freedom concert
that that immediately comes to mind not
that every not that anybody's
performance was the most amazing thing
I've ever seen that time just just
because they got a hundred thousand
people in the Golden Gate Park and just
did this thing that started essentially
with a de me out just borrowing phones
from you know people desks space in my
office around the corner because you
lived there around the corner at the
time that was a really super special day
um what else well the show I just saw
this weekend Foo Fighters at Wembley
Stadium you know I just played two
nights there and it was the biggest rock
shows attendance ever at at wembley
stadium was more than live earth it was
more than the original Live Aid they're
just incredibly huge in the UK for
whatever reason and mostly because the
hard work I mean each time I find myself
going to a lot of their shows in the UK
just because it always seems like the
biggest show they let her play there I
seen at wembley arena then earls court
unfortunately missed the hyde park show
they did why they did 85,000 people too
but then they did the two nights at
Wembley Stadium and for the last encore
they did to Led Zeppelin songs rock and
roll and ramble on with john paul jones
and Jimmy Page joining them so since I
couldn't be at the at the Led Zeppelin
reunion at the o2 last December I was
that was the closest I could get to it
there's definitely been I mean some of
the some of the artists I've worked with
I mean some of the Radiohead and Arcade
Fire shows yeah and then all fairness
everybody has been a lot of shows that
just been really special but those are
those two particularly transcended shows
oh you know what also i would say would
be the gorillas Demon Days live thing I
don't know if you ever saw those shows
there's a DVD if you get a chance to see
it what they did was they created a sort
of an imaginary you know it's imaginary
cartoon character band and they created
a tribute show to the band and I went to
see the premiere of a new manchester I
had no idea what to expect and I was
just blown away i wanted i stayed an
extra day to see it again and then they
did a week of shows at at the Apollo in
2006 and I remember you know I remember
hearing damon albarn who co-created the
girl is saying that that was the the of
all the stuff he's done with blur and
Molly and all this different stuff that
was like the most incredible